a free coke and welcome to another the
daily programmer webseries video and the
problem today we're going to be talking
about is number three one seven called a
coal ads tag system this one's pretty
straightforward and it shouldn't take
too long to cover so let's go ahead and
talk about it on the whiteboard break it
down and an implement in JavaScript side
so the coal ads tag system is kind of
defined like so basically you need to
give it some input for instance a a a we
need to continuously pop off and append
different things onto this queue or list
based on these production rules so the
algorithm kind of works like so we need
to remove the first two characters and
then we look at the first character and
append that to the end so in this case
we remove these two and we append BC at
the end and we continue doing this
process until we reach a halt case in
which our Q is equal to the length of
one so we should end up stopping this
whole simulation when we hit the final
input of a so hopefully that made sense
if not let's go ahead and walk through a
couple of steps and this is going to run
for at least like 20 or 30 iterations so
I'm not going to go through all them but
again starting off the input AAA we
remove the first two characters which
leaves us with this one here so we have
a and then we attend to the end whatever
the first character was every remove so
in this case at BBC so variation two
we're going to remove a b which leaves
us with c and then we're going to look
what a should convert to at the end so
again this is going to be a bc iteration
three we remove CB which leaves us with
c and we find what c converts to which
is Triple A keep doing that process
where we remove CA C converts to three
days and we continuously do that until
we hit our whole case which will be a so
this should be pretty obvious that you
need some type of loop for you to keep
on looping over your original input
while it's greater than or equal to
- right because when you reach the
string length of one that's when you're
done so you're probably need some type
of while loop and you need to keep on
looping and doing those two operations
where we remove the first two characters
look at what the first character was and
then append to the end of the input
based on these production rules so last
time just to make it clear let's write
it down we say loop while input length
greater than equal to two remove first
two characters tend to input based on
first character and then you just keep
the rapini
so that's pretty easy pseudocode we
should be able to map that to JavaScript
so let's go ahead and go to code panning
try to implement this algorithm and see
if we can reproduce the Collatz tag
system hi this is pretty fun to do it's
really short and simple so let's get to
it the first thing we need to do is the
query function so I'm going to call this
function C function tag system and it's
going to take an input which is going to
be or character array or string so I'll
just call it tape since I guess the tag
system does something on the tape I
don't really look into it too much but
it's going to read the Wikipedia maybe
we talk about it in the comments
discussion of the subreddit maybe you
can learn more about it but I'm just
trying to go over the algorithm but
anyway so we have a function called tag
system which I'm just going to go ahead
and return M steps so in this case I'll
say con steps is equal to int array and
that's going to be a barrier bowl or an
array where we can keep track of all the
steps and print them out in the console
and then down here just get set up I'll
go ahead and call tag system with
triple-a so this point if a function
called tax systems it's going to create
an array of steps and somewhere in the
algorithm in the middle we're going to
push those steps one by one as we
iterate over the different the rules
whatnot so the second thing it's kind of
useful to do is let's kind of create a
hash map so we can map the production
rules of what the first character should
be to what it needs to be appended to at
the end so we can say Const rules is
equal to an array or an object where a
maps to think that one maps to BC B maps
to a and C maps to Triple A so now we
have our production rules where we can
easily just ask it okay if I start with
an A what do I need to append well it's
going to be a bit BC if I ask for a see
if then it gets 3 a's and we'll see what
that's going to do later on so then to
our logic that we wrote out those three
different steps the first one is while
the tape is still greater than equal to
length of 2 alright so that means we
still have more than just a single a we
need to continuously do some steps and
at this point we can say steps dot push
the tape so what is the value of the
current string our tape at this
iteration and we're just going ahead and
push that in two steps and then the
second part of the rule was removing the
first two characters so we can do tape
that substring of two to give us
everything after the two characters and
set take equal to that
so that will set tape equal to itself
cut off the first two characters but
then we also do to opinion something at
the very end right which is where our
production roles come in so we can say
Plus rules and then we can say tape of
index 0 which was the very first
character and then finally we do step
stop push and push the final result of
the tape and then of course return steps
at the end so now I'm going to go ahead
and run this code and we see that it
does print out all the steps so it
starts with a a it goes a b c CB c CA a
and then continuously goes on until it
reaches the very last step where it just
gets an a and you can try this with you
know various different inputs to see
what happens so i'll try it with two
ways and see what the output is and it
just gives us three steps i could try it
with four A's I'm sure the outputs will
be much longer so just make this a
little bit easier to read let's go ahead
and print this out string applied so I
can say json dot stringify string is
fine and then pass it to tag systems
Fastenal pass it to for the indentation
level and then of course give us some
colons there are commas I mean clear
this go ahead run this
all right so now I can actually show you
since it was going up the screen before
all the different console outputs of all
the steps that it takes for it to reach
that ending halting character of a cool
so that pretty much wraps up the whole
problem of how do you solve the Colts
tag system and that subreddit it's
pretty straightforward you know just
keep on looping over the tape or the
string remove the first two characters
and then a pin to the end whatever the
production rules tell you to append and
then just continuously run this until we
reach the halting case which will just
be a single character a and then print
out the steps at the end and that's all
we do so hopefully this tutorial is
pretty good and hopefully this kind of
challenged your mind a little bit be
sure to LIKE this video if you thought I
was good and subscribe to free code camp
below alright thanks for watching